what is um amazing to me is have I  talked to someone who is so  steadfast hatred for Donald Trump I this  is unbelievable and this is where you  have to say cuckoo they hate him so much  they pay the seven dollars or five  dollars for gas than to have gas at a  dollar fifty or a dollar a year now  here's the other thing you go to the  supermarket you know groceries were very  reasonable When Donald Trump was in  office now you go to buy a gallon of  milk it's like six dollars right yes  everybody has to pay the same thing  whether you're Hispanic or  African-American or whatever everybody  goes to some Market they don't ask for  your voter registration card it's  amazing though that Biden has been able  to use as a scapegoat for his failures  placing it directly on Donald Trump